Creative people are getting a really
rough or they're not getting a break at
all and there are probably more creative
people doing non creative work in the
workforce than the other way around.
Oh definitely,
definitely,
and the thing is,
I don't want to paint too dismal a
picture about being creative because one
of the things that pays off big for
creative people is that they get to be
creative,
right?
There's great aesthetic joy in that in
depth,
and I've been privileged because I've
worked with more creative people than
than,
than would fall to the law,
let's say,
of the typical psychotherapist because
people often come and see me because
they've watched my videos online and
they deal with people who are interested
in those subjects tend to be creative
and one of the things I've really been
struck by,
first of all,
I've learned that for those of you who
are interested in such things that the
reason human psychology works is because
it works for creative people.
It doesn't work at all for non creative
people.
It's just false and slot for them.
They're not interested in it.
No,
it isn't how they think.
You mean as therapy?
Yeah,
there that it doesn't match.
It doesn't match their personalities.
Whereas creative people,
man,
they dream market typical dreams all the
time.
It's really interesting and also they
die if they're,
if they're not being creative,
they wither on the vine.
I had one client,
I really liked him.
He was,
he was a brilliant architect and his
rational mind was his worst enemy
because it just criticized everything.
He was hyper rational,
criticized everything and really in a
dark way and effectively,
you know,
is that if I could get him to not think
and just create,
he was a complete genius.
He could.
That's where all of the vitality in his
life was.
You know,
that's where the sap rose up inside the
dead tree that was sort of embedded
inside of him and it's very common with
creative people is that it's their life
blood and it really is from a biological
perspective.
This isn't some EPA phenomena.
It's,
it's,
it's built right into people in deeply.